you've got girls on tick tock
laughing joking injecting testosterone
into their thighs or showing their
Euphoria after having their breasts
removed I mean if that isn't self-harm
times a million I don't know what it is
hello and welcome to martial matters of
me Winston Marshall at The Spectator
today I'm joined by Kelly J Keen also
known as Posey Parker Kelly J it's a
woman's rights activist and campaigner
founder of let women speak
and standing for women both Grassroots
gender critical organizations kalije has
just come back from a trip of New
Zealand and Australia
where footage came out seeing her attack
and doused in tomato soup by radical
trans activists
Kelly J thank you so much for speaking
with me today you're very welcome thanks
for having me so considering the footage
I've seen uh
and which you've described you've
described the events the last week or so
as as you fearing for your life and that
seems
absolutely the case from the footage
I've seen surrounded by literal baying
mobs
actually that you've come to speak with
me today I I'm not quite sure how you
have the the strength to do it so
firstly thank you but how are you
feeling I'm all right
um yeah I don't know whether this is
sort of some latent trauma is going to
come along and
and bite me soon but now I'm okay okay
well um I want to get into a bit of the
prehistory but maybe we start with um
this last week so you were you were in
you're down under with uh let women
speak
uh
and what was the purpose of of the trip
what were you what were you hoping to
achieve why did you go to Australia New
Zealand well to be really brief about
what women speak is is basically we
create a space in which women can come
and speak I mean it's it's quite simple
um and women in their locality will come
uh and they will talk about local issues
but it will be basically centered around
what transgenderism and transgender
ideology is doing to women and their
families and their children
uh and so we decided to go to Australia
because I did a tour of America made a
film about it last year and the women in
Australia were like please come
and I've known about cases and things
happening in Australia for quite some
time and New Zealand so
um just put my ticket went and started
organizing these events nine were
planned
um eight ish we managed to do and then
the violence came and I had to flee
so what what do you think about your
message was resonating with women in in
Australia and New Zealand I mean you've
described New Zealand as the worst place
in the world for women that I've been
that you've got to fly through Dubai on
my way home
right so maybe it's changed since but no
your experience would suggest that that
certainly in the west it seems like the
worst place for women in the world
um what what is going on over there
before you went there what what are the
laws in Australia and in New Zealand uh
where where are the points of
contentions between uh women's rights
and trans rights um it's there
specifically well
to be fair it's the same the world over
anywhere that this ideology has has
um
taken hold it's it's textbook kind of
um the way it operates is is absolutely
identical so it will be changing the
laws it will be covert changing the laws
it's a top-down uh coercion of the
population so in Australia and New
Zealand
um in some places in Australia you can
lose custody of your children if you
don't affirm their gender the state will
come and take them away in Australia and
New Zealand the state will uh in schools
change your child's name uh pronouns and
treat them as the opposite sex and won't
even tell you
um in Australia and in parts of New
Zealand they are talking about a baby
having a sexuality
so it's it's all the sort of Foucault
Kinsey
um queer Theory and it's it's really
like just terrible in in some places in
Australia there is self ID in in New
Zealand that's happening too that means
any man for any reason can just call
himself a woman and have access to all
women's bases and rights we know that
Laurel Hubbard competed
um in the Olympics as a female athlete
and he's a you know he's a man not
particularly fit looking in his 40s
competing against women at the peak of
their Fitness at like age 23 who've
trained their whole lives in
weightlifting and the same in Australia
you have
um
a man called Hannah mathey who plays uh
Australian soccer a gay or Australian
football I think it's called against
tiny women he's like six foot three and
well built so there is just this the
same lies told here although a lot worse
which are men can be women women uh our
speech is compelled we're losing genuine
female language when we talk about
females uh you know the only in
Australia New Zealand Canada America the
only woman allowed to call herself a
woman or the only person allowed to call
themselves a woman is actually a man
so it seems like there's two things
there's the infringement of women's
rights as well as the issue of how
children are being treated uh who
identify differently and and was that
did you have with your trip were you
were you trying to address both those
issues separately or or was it more for
was it more for the women's rights
aspect or
well look it's called let women speak so
it's really about women telling their
own stories it's not I don't have an
agenda we don't have like we're going to
talk about this topic today we don't
even have an order of speakers I don't
know who's going to come and speak I
mean it's it's a it's a real genuine
Grassroots go along say to women this is
the place that you can speak what would
you like to come and say
um and for many women when they're
talking about the impact of this
particular ideology on their lives it
will be their own lives their own speech
and it will be their children you know
we had women who'd uh their daughters
didn't talk at all about
um the possibility of not being girls
and then all of a sudden within six
months they've gone from saying they're
trans to having their their breasts
removed so it's it's really serious yeah
um so uh what are these organizers do
you have microphones are you is it sort
of
group meetings Outdoors what what are
the let women speak events like what
were they like and so you were first was
it Sydney Brisbane Perth Melbourne and
Tasmania in
Australia's in there somewhere was just
before Melbourne
um so what were those were those all
different types of events no they're all
outside and they're outside because too
many venues will cancel us so rather
than allow a venue to cancel cancel us
we get permits uh we don't need permits
here so much but in Australia you need a
permit uh to speak so often we'll try to
do them outside of uh sort of
parliamentary houses
um
and uh yeah you just set up a microphone
and um so local women will organize
We'll advise them how to do it they will
organize Marshals
um and they will organize uh the the amp
the permits and the police presence
um and then we had uh you had to get
public liability insurance in order to
have these events but they're all
outside they're really
um it's an open invitation for anyone
but we do have a role that women speak
first and then men can speak uh-huh okay
and so they there's a sort of Crescendo
through the events culminating with uh
the incidents in in New Zealand and it
seems like New Zealand was another level
of of Hell really yeah and uh there was
the the Tomato incident where trans
extremist Eliana rabashkin said
I want her to be full of blood because
that's what she's advocating for she's
advocating for our genocide now I've
done fair amount of research for this
interview and I found no such advocation
um uh nothing of the sort not even
violence let alone genocide it seems
very much like a peaceful protest that
um that your history is what happened
there in in New Zealand I mean it seemed
terrifying
well the Prime Minister had talked about
me
um the there was a high court case to
try and stop my Visa I mean I I was on
the news apparently loads before I even
got there it wasn't just
um lying it wasn't just sorry
exaggerating it was it was Bare face
lies about me uh
well in one of my live streams when I'm
talking about the New Zealand prime
minister trying to sort of talk about me
not going to New Zealand and revoking my
Visa
I'm holding it my zip on my piece of
clothing and I do this as I'm moving my
zip and they blur out my hand and say
I'm giving a white power symbol whilst
talking about the prime minister of New
Zealand like just nuts what he what they
inadvertently did they did two things
number one they whipped up a frenzy but
the other thing they did is they told
everybody my name on a repeated like so
many times that people like well what is
this woman what does she stand for how
can I like why is it why are we stopping
her from coming into the country and
then they look me up and then they agree
with what I say and what I stand for so
it had um
you know they did me many favors I mean
obviously there was a little bit of a
price to pay for that but it's a
tactical thing with media and I've seen
it happen to me where your Wikipedia
they come out they can manipulate
everything that's on there I've had that
happen to me uh it's bombardment of
media
um pieces to sort of cloud out any
semblance of the truth now to anyone who
might not know what do you stand for
what are those things that actually when
people dig they find oh this is what
Posey Park is about actually I agree
with that what are those things what are
the key things that I don't want women
to lose the rights that we've fought for
so women only spaces uh women women
female language just use for women
um
uh children not being stabilized uh that
we really have a think about whether or
not anybody should transition but
certainly anybody under the age of 25 I
think should find it very difficult to
make such catastrophic
um medical sort of decisions that harm
their bodies uh that I would like to
totally get rid of the gra which is the
gender recognition act I don't think we
should have legal fictions I think a
truly tolerant society would actually
say if John wants to be called Janet and
he wants to live a a peaceful life and
not bother anyone and not
um
not going to women's spaces and force
other people to be compelled to pretend
they also see John as Janet then you
know that a tolerant society would allow
that but we have a state that basically
says if you don't go along with that we
will punish you uh so that's what I want
to get rid of there's the state
involvement
and the schools and the Judiciary and
all the other place all the other arms
of the state I want them out of
um
this out of women's rights so uh back to
New Zealand Australia but but regardless
State various politicians came out
against you you already mentioned the
New Zealand prime minister Chris Hipkins
I'm not quite he seemed to be a little
bit vague in commentary saying that the
the the debate was unhelpful rather it
didn't seem to be a straight out
criticism necessarily although neither
does it seem to be support but there's
been more explicit condemnation Michael
Wood New Zealand's immigration Minister
said I would prefer if
if Parker never set foot in New Zealand
I find many of her views repugnant and
am concerned
by the way in which she caught some of
the most vile people and groups around
including white supremacists was it in
Melbourne that there were some white
supremacists who came yeah
um now again Michael Woods claims that
you caught such people but I've had I've
in my research for this interview I've
have no such thing what can you tell me
the story behind the white supremacist
group that were there yeah I absolutely
can from my point of view so we were in
Parliament myself and more more
Redeeming the MP and the security said
oh there's some men in black with black
masks and we were like oh antifa right
that's just the Assumption we made
because that's my experience of antifa
um and when we went out we couldn't see
those men because we were on steps and
they were parallel to us and there was
also another rally about Freedom
um I'm assuming that might be about
lockdowns and vaccines and stuff I have
no idea and then there was some
Socialist Workers type party there were
also tras and there were some tras and
I'm I'm told there was another group
that was apparently six groups and so we
were giving our talks we didn't see
those men we didn't interact with those
men
until we saw them give a Nazi salute
and they were opposite us
um
in front of the trans rights activists
now I'm not saying it was orchestrated
I'm just saying that if you wanted to
discredit women
um that would be a really good way to do
it to sort of imply that we were somehow
connected to a group that we had no
we had nothing to do with them they had
nothing to do with me uh the last I
heard people that supported uh Nazi
ideology weren't great fans of women's
rights you know so it's it's
Preposterous that they came to have
anything to do with us plus they had no
marcation on them there was not a single
Nazi symbol
amongst any of them the only thing you
knew is the Nazi salute it just feels
just feels really Sinister and
orchestrated and I don't know who would
do it I don't know who had would have
the power to do it certainly wasn't the
place that they were on there that were
there on the day
but it might have been someone you
mentioned that Moira deeming so she was
uh she's a member of the Liberals in
Victoria
um uh party and she's been suspended for
her association with you did you know
that yeah what how do you feel about
have you been in contact with her since
um I have been in contact and I'm
disgusted but I'm really hopeful in
these sort of situations where somebody
is publicly flogged and for something
that is most people would think was
ludicrous I'm hoping that someone with
her resilience and resolve and good
moral standing I'm hoping that this
makes her the leader the next leader of
that party because I think people will
see a leader and a woman with conviction
who is willing to stand up for what she
believed in which is severely lacking in
in Australian politics do you have a
sense so we've talked already about how
the media just have swarmed around this
and besmirching you how politicians came
against you we're seeing in this country
how at The Ballot Box when it comes to
voting actually if you the the the
radical trans agenda is very
unpopularized with Nicola sturgeon do
you have a sense in Australia and New
Zealand whether anything it's similar
whether normal people actually see the
radical side and think maybe they've
gone too far or do they support the
radical movement I don't think any
normal person supports uh massive blokes
playing against women in sport or their
daughters not being able to use a female
only space without seeing an adult's
penis I don't you know I think it's
it's foolish to think that people are
going along with it people people have
no idea
and I think that the narrative in
Australia is totally uh sewn up on their
like their ABC their state broadcaster
doesn't cover this at all just covers it
from a vulnerable or let's trans the
kid's point of view you know and I'm
just I guess it's really easy to
convince a population I didn't realize I
think we look back at
um Germany in the 1930s and we all ask
or I certainly used to ask myself how do
you get how do you coerce people to do
such evil things and I don't think it's
that hard you just needed the right
amount of fear the a decent level of
propaganda and punishment for
questioning the narrative yeah yeah well
you mentioned there antifa what when you
said you had normal experiences with
antifa what is it what has that been
oh they come to all of our events now so
around the world uh yeah I mean in
America I couldn't go to Portland when I
so I did a film of dates throughout
America and I couldn't I couldn't go to
Portland because they were really
serious credible threats on my life uh
but yeah they come to all the events and
they're in they're they're properly
insane and I don't mean that as like oh
they're just so horrible I mean
they have psychotic yeah they look
psychotic they make noises a lot of the
the girls look really quite Disturbed
um and
I was in the middle of this mob in
Chicago and they're all close really
close and they're allowed to scream in
your ear as long as they don't touch a
tiny Speck of your skin they're allowed
to be right up in your face and just In
This Moment everything slowed really
slowed and went muffled and I'm just
looking around and
it is like something out of a movie and
I just I just thought oh I've really got
to do this I just I I just have to do
this you know there's I don't know
anyone else that's doing this and it's
it just has to be done so that that was
again those are part of let women speak
yes tours maybe you could give me a bit
of this history of letting women speak
it started as a Speaker's Corner yeah
yeah so um on International women's day
a couple of women uh Katie Wally and
Venice Allen they they said oh why don't
we go and do a Speaker's Corner because
we started doing stuff in Halls and
we're beginning to get canceled and it
was difficult so we thought for
international women's day we're going to
speaks Corner that might have been like
2019 and then it was so well attended
and Brilliant and I said well I'm going
to come and do this every month let's do
it the last Sunday of every month and
then obviously we had lockdown but we
did them right up until we weren't
allowed uh and then lots of women all
over the country because I also do
something called Turf talk Tuesday which
is the phone in on my channel and I have
a quite a lively
YouTube channel and they were like can
you come here and can you come to
different parts of the country you can't
make it to London so the first one we
did was the first Speaker's Corner out
of London which was Nottingham
and trans rights activists turned up and
started shouting and just organically
women started shouting let women speak
let women speak and it was just such a
lovely and it's not really asking
permission it's it's about
um creating the environment in which
women can speak so it's just gone from
there and so now it's called let women
speak it's a rallying cry it's
frequently trending on Twitter
um and I'm yeah I'm really proud of it
but it's it's the essence of the whole
let women speak uh event and campaign is
that it's it's all women-led and it's
all just beautifully organic and
coincidental it's not contrived which I
think why it comes across is sincere and
honest okay and before and before let
women speak you came to prominence with
the billboard at the labor Party
Conference in 2018 which I think just
wrote the definition of a woman which is
an adult human female yeah uh what
happened before then that led up to the
billboard because then there was I'm
kind of curious to understand how how
your journey has come to this point
where you're like a lightning rod on
this issue I mean so and and it's an
international it's a global issue uh the
the the dividing line between the
infringement of trans rights and women's
rights on each other and that uh debate
and that and that um very contentious uh
issue of our times and I I want to
understand how you've got that and and
so what happened leading up to the
billboard that
where does Posey Parker come from okay
so I was happily on the left uh I had no
idea that I was in some Echo chamber I
genuinely thought that uh after the
Coalition between the lib Dems and the
conservatives that we would vote that we
would vote in a labor government I
thought that was coming and then David
Cameron was voted out in I write I
started joining Lefty women groups on
Facebook and they were just became
heavily populated with what I would
kindly call men in dresses
um so this would be late transitioning
men who basically 10 years ago we would
have called transvestites
um and then the language was changing
and I just said one day to one of these
men do you really identify as a woman
well all hell broke loose and it wasn't
just him the women was so defended him
so much like it was vitriolic it was so
aggressive
and I was told this is something you
can't talk about and I was like oh okay
well this is what I want to talk about
then because this is nuts and I was a
stay-at-home mother I've got four
children happily married
um had actually started as a speech
issue rather than a rights issue
absolutely it's a free speech well I had
no idea so in 2016 I wrote a letter to
later to sort of called grieving the
left and it was all about
when it started when I first peaked and
Peak trans is when you understand what's
going on it's a bit like red pill and
when I peaked I am I thought well they
won't do this to kids and then I found
out they're doing it to Children I'm
like well it won't be in sport and then
I find out in sport well they won't use
the word woman for themselves and then
you know in every kind of uh
barrier I thought would not be broken
was completely obliterated by this this
movement this cult
um and so I I was just in secret little
groups and then
um and then I was interviewed under
caution in early 2018 for six tweets so
then that put my name out there what
were the tweets oh I'm I misgendered a
trans rights activist in America who
said that prostitution was a rite of
passage for uh Teenage trans girls
um I said that it was wrong to castrate
a 16 year old boy and take him to
Thailand which is what the CEO of
mermaids had done Susie Green yeah so
she reported me to the police
um and they've they got my contact
details from Twitter at a time when
Jihadi John was protected you know it
was so it was like next level and I was
thinking well this would be great I'll
go along I'll have an interview under
caution I got really wonderful uh
solicitor I'll go along and maybe we'll
go to court and everyone will go oh
goodness that's such a terrible thing we
must look at this issue and no it didn't
happen at all and everyone's just
carried on
um so
then um I got really admonished and
accused of terrible things vaguely by a
left-wing women's group who would call
themselves gender critical what was the
name of the group women's Place UK so
they put a statement out that's still
out there for everybody to see and it's
uh nasty and it implies that I'm racist
um but it doesn't actually make any
substantial uh allegations so it's not
actionable but it's you know it creates
a bad environment so
I sort of went away I was like well I
still want to do something
but I can't do it with my name because
I've been so badly
defamed so I just came up with the
billboard and I I sold t-shirts with the
dictionary definition of the word woman
and stickers to raise the money which is
only 700 pounds and I put billboard up
so that was it you put the billboard
billboard up outside the labor Party
Conference why did you choose labor
party uh when it was the tourists who
were in government
well because that just is good timing
and we could find a billboard so you
know you just look at different places
and it didn't really matter where the
billboard was to be honest it was good
that it was
um in the same city as a labor Party
Conference it just needed some trans
activists to to make a fuss and I had no
idea that the billboard company would
remove it and then put me on TV to talk
about it so in in the in the time since
in the UK there's been a cause for
celebration I think uh somewhat maybe
that's a little bit over the top but
particularly with uh the ordered closing
of uh gids at Tavistock yeah
um do you feel like you're message is is
finally having an impact
Helen and I did a talk so Stanley for
women did a talk at the House of Lords
where we did connect some of those uh
doctors to government and the House of
Lords and we really did instigate some
things uh with that talk we called it
first Do no harm
but I'm skeptical actually whether the
closing of the Tavistock is as much of a
win as as I might like it to be because
I think it might go out to the regions
now and that could be two things either
one that could be that everything is
done covertly and we don't really uh we
all think we've won and we don't and we
look away or it could be that when you
look at Regional budgets that when
doctors are dealing with regional
budgets they might not want to spend
quite so much money on this but the
Chelsea and Westminster is about to open
a wing specifically for sort of
phalloplasty type surgeries which is
when you take all the Flesh of a forearm
you fashion it into a tube and that's
supposed to be a penis uh it's a it's
got a really extraordinarily High
failure rate because oh I don't know
it's quite difficult to actually make a
penis out of an arm and the money spent
on it is is vast so those private
searches it wouldn't be NHS funded no
this is an NHS hospital this is NHS as I
understand it got that through there's a
Freedom of Information uh by one of the
women that called into tough talk and
she's been doing she's in the NHS and
she's been doing some research on it and
it's it's a bit horrifying
well
um that's disappointing to hear because
one of the things that's made my blood
boil on this issue is particularly
having just read Hannah barnes's book
time to think about the the history of
um the Tavistock and kids is is that our
taxes have gone towards paying for the
puberty blockers and cross-sex hormones
of
all of these children who are mutilated
for like not to even begin on on what's
going on in schools and and and the
confusion by not being able to Define
man and woman but uh that we've been
paying for them and that they will be
infertile and and this is irreversible
damage
uh I was it was a big relief for me to
hear that that the Tavistock is is
closed but maybe I should be more alert
that it's it's not the end of that story
well I do worry if labor getting in the
next election what will happen to all
that anyway because they do seem to be
quite captured explain well they've just
put something out you know that they're
gonna
um
they're going to change gender
recognition act they're going to make it
more do they say how exactly no but I
can only imagine it's got to be self-id
right it's got to be easier to identify
I mean they've taken gender dysphoria
off the table you don't even need that
anymore if you get self ID
um not that I even think that's a good
enough reason to create illegal fiction
but also they're going to ban conversion
therapy now conversion therapy
is all sorts of things for different
people and of course abusive practices
uh should be uh
should have some sort of restriction and
ban on them uh any abusive practices but
saying to a child that you actually
aren't a boy when you are um a girl
and saying to them that you know just
like you know this can be perfectly
normal or you're you're sucked into a
cult or advising parents to get their
kids offline like those sort of that is
not conversion therapy that is that is
responsible therapy and they will ban it
well it seems like we're what's actually
been happening is that um and again this
is Hannah Barnes goes into this in her
book but we're converting we the state
has been converting gay kids into
becoming trans kids I mean if if that
isn't conversion therapy what exactly is
conversion therapy absolutely and
there's um it's called the memorandum of
understanding for psychotherapists and
they're basically not allowed to do
anything other than a firm I mean it's
that's just Bonkers to have other than a
what sorry a firm someone so if a child
comes and says I'm a boy they're not
allowed to say that they're not and
that's been quite some time that sort of
capture and then you've got autism
societies that are captured and
promoting it when we know that autistic
children are far more susceptible to
this sort of black and white ideology or
the fact that 90 of them are likely to
be bullied in school and ostracized and
not have any friends and then they find
comfort and a sort of a One-Stop shop
solution to their distress and it isn't
it's just a different sort of distress
and a high percentage of them have
experienced trauma beforehand
um a high percentage of of them as I've
already said are just gay kids or
autistic kids as you mentioned one of
the phenomenon there uh is that the
demographic on the children's side has
been that it has gone from being a
minority uh female to majority female
yes in the children thing
identifying as trans or or
non-gender conforming or whatever the
right to determinant terminology is
there and as a woman's right activist I
I wondered what um why you think that is
what's going on there and and what can
be done about that well I think it
possible like this is just from just
from a common sense point of view I
think it probably used to be really
effeminate boys and it's very difficult
to be an effeminate boy and the CEO of
mermaids for example she gave a talk
um and she talked about it still Susie
Green Susie Green so she talked about
her son having Barbies and stuff and
then Dad came home one day when he was
three or four and said no son of mine
will play with dolls and threw them all
out now that's for girls I'm sure he
must have said that's for girls so then
that little boy said that he was a girl
because he just wanted to play with
dolls um
so I think that is probably
quite a common route for those little
boys into this now what you've got is
the social contagion which is well
documented for girls you know they'll I
would imagine uh girls who start
starving themselves and anorexia still
is the biggest killer of teenage girls
so I understand in this country
um so you've got the social contation of
that
um girls turn all of their distress and
Trauma into self-loathing
um so it'll be eating disorders other
forms of body dysmorphia cutting I mean
you've got girls on tick tock
uh laughing joking injecting
testosterone into their thighs or
showing their uh their Euphoria after
having their breasts removed I mean if
that isn't
kind of self-harm times a million and
getting medical surgery in order to
further your self-harm and self-loading
I don't know what it is so what can we
do about it
I think we just have to put laws into
place that you you can't do it that
surgeons can't do it that doctors can't
do it
um I think we take the state
out of it like nobody said about
anorexia hey you know what yeah you are
fat Let's Help let's give you a a
gastric band and help you starve
yourself to death a medical community
wouldn't have done that and yet they are
um there's a there's a chap in uh Holly
Street
I believe he is he does gender affirming
surgeries or he mutilates distressed
girls
um and he's a just a regular plastic
surgeon
and he's got sort of oil paintings of
himself doing breast surgery like
slicing into breasts
um there's something deeply Sinister and
misogynist about saying to girls do you
know what if you're not if you're not
finding your way about this world that
great why don't you just opt out
I've thought about that a bit in the
it's very hard to put yourself in the
it's hard enough to put yourself in the
mind of a regular surgeon because to
that person has to detach themselves and
for doing what is largely important work
but grueling like cutting our bodies
yeah
but I cannot for the life of me put
myself in the mind of a surgeon who cuts
off the genitalia of another human being
let alone a young human being I don't
know what what it would take to actually
allow themselves to do that what
psycholog psychologically how on Earth
can they can they be not just taking the
flesh off the arm to create the penis uh
or the so-called penis but actually
cutting away at the genitalia itself
like that it's just the most how is that
I can't bring myself to it well I'd
agree with you I'd agree with you
um look in America and private surgeons
here
I I don't think it's high can they I
think it's how much how much uh we'll
we'll let them sell their souls but
these a lot of these plastic surgeons
here are people that have been you know
augmenting women's breasts to sort of
for devastating proportions or any
proportion at all like they're in an
industry where they say I'll take your
insecurity and I'll I'll sell you a
solution for a long time so I think
those people are already in the business
of of something pretty horrifying this
is just Next Level isn't it this is
I'm not a religious woman but it it
seems to me like it's relatively demonic
um
um on a slightly more positive note
you've had the support of some Heroes
um most famously JK Rowling and that
must be very encouraging uh she came out
and saying uh speaking of what she saw
happening to you in New Zealand women
have become used used to lies threat to
violence and outright denial of reality
but if you imagine anyone feels defeated
think again your men's rights activists
showed the world exactly who they are it
must be very encouraging to have someone
like her yeah she's yeah I mean she's
the reason that two of my sons actually
bothered to pick up a book at all you
know not just because her stories are
great just just the fact of
somebody who doesn't read to somebody
that reads so I'm indebted to her
already but yes her her very well
um crafted tweets are always welcome
well she's another person who's like
herself in uh just called besmirched and
called Everything Under the Sun and
there's a woman who's generated billions
for the British economy
gives billions well maybe certainly tens
of millions to in tax and then it seems
like what money she has left seems to be
going towards charity I mean it's just
incredible that this great really great
woman a Great British person has been
treated as she has and it's just you're
another person in in that category where
you're doing great things and they're
trying to
um come at you and one of the one of the
uh
one of the more prominent people coming
at you was it was the singer and uh
activist Billy Bragg yeah
um who who's sort of flung a torrent of
of tweets at you have you been engaging
in in his um correspondences I have a
little bit because it's just he's not
the only Lefty misogynist who um has has
targeted me but he does seem rather
obsessed I mean I have I've reminded him
that I am married happily married and
all of his attention is is uh is
unwelcome
um
well that's really a nice way of dealing
with it
um uh let's hope he gets the message
um you are starting
the party of women yes I am so this is
you're going to run against secure
starmer at the next election yes I am
what can you tell us
well look we have to force these
politicians to talk about it they have
to take its stance and they have to
either look like a fool and say that
they don't know what a woman is or
they'll have to admit that they know
what one is and then we get this
conversation like let's do it uh it's
been far too long that people have been
a little bit too polite so when a
politician
evades the question they're not pressed
is that everyone's a little bit
frightened of it
um and I'm not so I thought let's run
against kirst armor let's encourage
women all over the country to run for
PCC or local councils or MPS like well
however they feel they can they can get
their foot in the door to represent
women or represent themselves uh and ask
the right questions
in places where decisions are made where
as yet
when people talked about men going into
women's prisons it seems like nobody
said what about the women and so we just
want people in those rooms to say what
about the women
it also means that they'll have to put
Billboards up because at the moment
nobody will so I can return to my first
Port of Call which is uh to to just put
these Billboards up and provoke
conversation for everybody that's what
it's about I don't think I'm gonna win
but I will win uh in so much as I will I
will break the silence you've described
that you felt let down by by labor and I
assume this is why you're running
against in kierstama rather than Rishi
sunak yeah how they let you down
well I was on the left I had no idea
maybe I was just totally ignorant and
naive but I had no idea how much they
hated women but
each and so many of the the labor
politicians Lisa nandi was asked whether
or not a child rapist should be in
prison with women she said yes
um when was that oh this was uh it's on
my channel actually a friend of mine Dr
Julia long went to a labor party
hustings I think it must have been and
she was directly asked
about this specific prisoner whether he
should be moved to a women's prison
estate and she sort of said yes and they
talk about respecting trans identities
and
um so many of the like labor have put
that thing out today about trans
visibility it's just
I just didn't realize how much they
hated us I really thought they were on
the side of women which is more for me
do you take so when you see like trans
Dev visibility or the trans flag do you
really you interpret that as just
anti-woman you don't interpret that as
you know you say oh I didn't realize how
much they hate women when you see that
flag is that not a bad faith
interpretation of what of what they're
trying to do because they would say that
there's
there's trans rights and and there's no
denying that there are kids with gender
dysphoria
um uh whether they're trans that's again
that's there's a debate around that uh
do you really see that flag as an
affront yes yeah because I don't know
what trans rights are except the right
for men who use women's spaces
um we'd I don't think it's true uh that
uh trans people that call themselves
trans don't have access to health care
they might not have access to
extortionate healthcare which we don't
feel is life-saving but then some women
with stage four breast cancer don't have
access to the healthcare that they want
I would say that those women are far
more important but if you ask somebody
what are trans rights it really is women
are important or the the issue they're
they're the women are important I I
don't think it's important for us to
endorse
um falsehoods I I think it's we have a
duty to people that are confused to help
them understand that they are all their
bodies you know we don't get a choice we
don't get to detach ourselves from our
bodies we are our bodies so
um I think it would be much more
fruitful to help people accept the body
they're in that's what we do to people
with profound disabilities we don't you
know we help and encourage people with
uh I knew a woman who did a PhD research
project on children with facial
deformities and we just help those
children accept
that this is the body that they're born
in and you know that that would be a
much more uh fruitful healthy thing to
do okay so uh back to then the the
you're running in the election uh what
um uh do you what do you want from your
supporters how can uh people get get
behind you and in touch if they wanted
to support you on this
um so I have a
um a website called standing for women
and you can contact us with uh party of
women in the subject we are I've I've
read we're registering the party as we
speak there's loads of legal stuff to do
um but we will be announcing properly uh
after the coronation but it will we're
just gonna hit the ground running I just
I I just come I just can't wait I can't
wait for women women feel emboldened at
the moment
um they they watched what happened in
New Zealand
um many of them watch really thinking
that it probably wasn't gonna come out
of that alive
um and I think they're a little bit like
right okay it's time you know it's time
to do this and so we have to take it
into the political Arena great uh well
uh I guess my my last question would be
um what do you want what at what point
would you feel like you've achieved what
you need to achieve I
there's a number of things number one I
would like all uh government sort of
arms whether it's education the police
uh the NHS the Judiciary as a whole uh I
would like all of them to get out of the
business of telling women what we can
and cannot say and I would like them to
stop indoctrinating children and I would
like them to stop
um you know the police I've been
involved with the police on five
occasions now over this issue I would
like the police to be totally neutral
again
um and we stopped telling these lies I
would like the gra to have evaporated
Into Thin Air and that people are
embarrassed to ever say they endorsed it
and Lobby groups and and money out of
government
so it's just simple I just would like to
get back to a place of Common Sense and
Truth
um which maybe we were never there but I
didn't know about it uh so back to the
point where uh women could say a woman
is an adult human female without fearing
some sort of Retribution
well Kelly J Keen
uh thank you so much for speaking with
me and uh or I said posey Parker of
course is thank you for taking the time
up in this chaotic hectic time and uh
particularly over the last couple of
weeks you've had astonishing I'm very
grateful for it and I'm sure listeners
would have found that fascinating thank
you so much thank you so much
[Music]
thank you